So, YouTube celebrity culture is a
topic that seams to have been
talked about near to death on this website
recently, and with good reason too.
It is very important.
Personally, I didn't want to
jump in unless I felt like
I had something new and valuable
to add to the conversation,
but I think I finally think I do.
I think I finally think I do.
There are a lot of worthy videos
surrounding this topic,
and so what I'll do is I'll make a
playlist of some of my favorites
and link to that at the end should
you want to watch some more,
but there was one video in
particular that I saw yesterday
that really struck a
chord with me.
It's by a YouTuber called
"VickyThePixie,"
and everything that I have to say today
is directly inspired by her video.
The bulk of the conversation, so far,
about YouTube celebrity culture
has surrounded this idea
of the ever widening gap
between big famous YouTube
stars and their fans.
Where previously I used to be pretty
uncomfortable with the idea of
referring to big YouTubers as
"YouTube celebrities,"
nowadays I don't even bother adding the
"YouTube" to the beginning of that phrase.
These people appear on
magazine covers,
they're on the sides of buses,
they get stopped in the street,
they can draw crowds of
thousands of people.
In my mind, the biggest of the big
YouTubers are just celebrities now.
And while I have to assume that a lot of these
now celebrities feel very happy being just that -
maybe it was what they were always
hoping for when they started out -
not everybody who has that popularity
feels as comfortable with it.
Being screamed at when you walk into
a room can be terrifying for some people
Being told that you're somebody's idol
and that they look up to you
as a perfect example of
humanity when you know that
there are many flawed sides to you
that you're not showing them,
for some people, can
be very worrying.
The big YouTubers on this side of things,
I think, they don't want to feel "other."
They don't want to feel special.
They want to feel normal.
They want you to see
them as human beings.
They don't want you
to idolize them.
They want you to imagine
them complexly,
and I do genuinely think that
that is all good advice.
I know that point of view very well because
I've been there many times myself,
and I think it also shows that those
people who are giving that advice
are taking their positions as
role models very seriously,
and that's also a
good thing,
but, and there is a "but,"
and it's a very big "but,"
and I'm going to touch
that "but" now.
We've talked nice and loud now
about our big YouTuber problems,
and, apparently, we've
decided as a group that
you are going to be the ones
to fix our problems for us.
It's your job now to
think more about us,
to imagine us more complexly because
we're people too, you know,
and we're forgetting that this gap that
exists that we're trying to close
exists between two groups of people
because we're treating it, I think,
in a very one-sided way.
What Vicky talked about in her video,
and that I agree with,
is that some big YouTubers, not all, but some,
have just as much of an issue imagining
their audiences complexly as some
members of their audience
have imagining them complexly.
And I believe this, not as a hunch,
but because when I've spent time
with some big YouTubers in the past and
they decide to tell stories about their fans,
the only stories they
seem to want to tell
are those about their crazy
fans or their stupid fans.
And I don't even know if I can remember a
time when I've heard those same YouTubers
talk about their experiences
with their friendly fans
or their considerate fans
or their intelligent fans
because I think they have a hard time
remembering that those people exist.
And I wish that I could attest to being a perfect
example on the other side of that coin,
but I can't because, let's be fair, it's hard
enough to imagine one person complexly
let alone hundreds of thousands
of people or millions of people,
but at the same time, I don't think
that means we shouldn't try.
Maybe there is something different about
the people who I've met who watch my videos
because I've always felt very proud
to have a group of people
who support my work who are
so considerate and respectful
and intelligent and friendly,
but my guess is that my audience
isn't unique in that respect
and that most people who
watch YouTube are like that.
There are always going to be
those individuals that I meet
who do seem to see me as being
something otherworldly,
but the assumption that I think is right
to make is that you already know
that you're not watching
a person right now,
that this is a YouTube video that
I have written and performed
and edited and uploaded
for your enjoyment.
You don't need me to tell you that
because I believe you are smart enough
to figure that out for yourself.
And so that is what I would like to offer as a
potential first step towards closing this gap
is that I believe we need some
more respect on both sides.
Hopefully that wasn't too mean.
Thanks for watching.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Okay, gang, you know the drill.
Here's my most recent video
in case you missed it.
Here's the playlist that I mentioned,
starting with the video from Vicky,
and I'm not going to try and
say anything funny right now
because it doesn't feel appropriate
for some reason. Goodbye.
SILENCE